Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace
launching their new campaign.
Make your next move. Make your next
move and set new goals for this year.
Lock down your next move idea with a
unique domain and create a website to
launch today by using offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
Make your next move with
Squarespace more@squarespace.com
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich
Radiolab. We're talking about, well,
what are we talking about? We're
talking about sports games. Games. Yeah.
You know what,
what we're really talking about is a
fundamental behavior of everyone on earth,
including like wolves and
cats, wolves and cats.
I was with you broadening more than I
would broaden, but that's, you know,
well go in there. Come on.
Like what a little bullets do.
They don't play a football? No, but
they tussled yes. You mean like,
like they play? Yes. Like
human babies. Yeah. Okay.
Babies and young children spend almost
all of their time playing seems so
natural. We don't even think about it.
So let's just go with that thought.
This is Alison Gopnik.
She's a developmental psychologist at
the University of California at Berkeley.
Big Sports Fan. Yeah. Baseball
Oakland Fan. Professionally though,
she studies kids and she's got
an interesting idea. She says,
if you look at kids, how
they play over time. Yes.
You see that at the center of their play.
There's this really interesting tension
that exists. Tension of what kind? Well,
you can actually hear it. So we'll get
back to Alison and just one moment.
Here's a four year old girl named Rosa.
Yes. Listen to her. Describe
her imaginary friend to her dad.
And how does um, her
mind, you know, Antarctica
[inaudible] the moon. Um, what,
what was she doing in the Antarctic
in Antarctica? You know how she,
what do you use to be
boring? To Keep what?
Warren, why don't
she got lacquered? See I
was scared for too long.
How to skate and what prompted her
to move from Antarctica to the moon.
Okay.
Don't one doctorals high and now she's
thinking she wants to move back to me and
talk
it. Preschool children,
you start seeing this wonderful
flowering of pretend play.
The children are becoming Ninjas and
princesses and superheroes at first says
Ellison. This is what
plays all about venting,
making a crazy psychedelic connections,
complete improv. You get this period.
Just explore. Just innovate
came down from the team. We don't
know spice host mice of course,
but if you fast forward just a couple
of years, so not four anymore with six,
six year olds,
the vibe totally changes because
now it's all about rules.
Just the freezer. Get the Taggart,
the freezer tacky your
routing yes. Taps you.
Yeah.
Okay. Actually brave is free
with six year olds. It just sounds
really different. You hear a lot
this,
a lot of yelling about what's
allowed, what isn't allowed.
Last time you started out with the ball.
In some ways I think the
school age children are
practicing being in a society,
they're practicing having laws,
they're practicing having rules.
I don't know yet.
Sort of, uh, developing
a theory of sociologists.
So you've got these two modes of play.
You got the three year old
inventor who's like, okay,
I'm just going to make this happen.
I'm going to create
something new in the world.
Then you've got the six year old enforcer
[inaudible].
You can't just create what you want.
The world is bigger than we are.
We need rules.
And one of the things that's really
interesting about the games that seem to
stick is that the greatest games like
baseball are games that let us experience
the world in both those ways at
the same time. In other words,
like a good game is a kind of weird,
constantly shifting war between the three
year old in us and that the six year
old,
I think she's probably correct because
there are games which suffer from a lack
of the tension she's describing this
one game in particular. Okay. With that,
I didn't know whether
you've played it lately,
but we heard about it from this Guy
Brian Christian brighter. Yeah. Yeah.
It was on a recent show
talking about robots,
but he also mentioned this little
a moment. Yes, it's a moment.
So yeah, at the World Checkers
Championship in Glasgow,
Scotland in 1863 it is James
Wiley against Robert Martins,
the two best checker players in the world.
Wiley Wiley playing a 40 game series,
all 40 games opened with the same three
or four moves and all 40 games were
draws. Really? Yes. Not only that,
21 of the 40 games are
the exact same game,
meaning that move from move
from move, they were precise.
Duplicates of each other start to finish.
Every single move was the same. Yeah.
Yep. You know, can you imagine?
It's like a month of checkers.
How exactly does that happen? We'll see.
These guys were professional
checkers players. Yes.
So they studied moves that
other competitors had made.
They would write them down and memorize
them and they became a kind of catalog.
So at, at a certain point, every move
you saw on the checkerboard, you'd think,
oh yeah.
That one checkers had hit this point
where the conventional wisdom about what
was the proper move to play had gotten
to this point where there was now
basically a perfect game of checkers
and with the world title on the line,
both players played that perfect
game over and over and over.
They stuck to the script.
So this was really rock bottom
for the checkers community.
Yeah, so there you go. That's why
no one plays checkers anymore.
Some people play jackers I played, I
played jackers. What? No you don't.
Checkers is fine. As long as you
don't play it for too long too. Well,
you're a lame checker player.
You could play checkers forever.
Well then what's the point?
I mean why would you play a game that's
been gobbled up stead but by the way,
this thing that you just said
killed checkers. Yeah. This concept
has a name it's called called the book
[inaudible].
The danger is that the entire game
stays in book the whole time and that
dangerous has, Brian is not specifically
confined to checkers. Occasionally.
Very rarely in the chess world you'll
see two grandmasters play the exact same
game that another pair of
grand masters played, you know,
a year before and they'll get booze and
jeers all over the Internet and as a
result now chess, let me, let me
talk about chess. Okay. Chess.
The book in chess is huge.
It started in the 16th century and for
hundreds of years players were keeping
track
moves and counter moves and counter
counter counter counter moves until by the
1950s of course like to library.
It actually was a library in the Moscow
central chess club. And who's this? Uh,
this is uh, Fred Friedl.
He's a chess analyst and one of the few
non Russians to have seen this room.
Yes, the huge musty room.
All these shelves and there were little
boxes and the boxes contained little
cards,
index codes from each of these cards
documented a particular game of chess from
the past. And for awhile
this was all a secret.
There were about three or
four players in the world,
all Russian who had access to one.
One of these guys had a big game.
They would go to this library and say,
all right, I've got this opponent,
he's a Polish guy. [inaudible]
something rather, give me all this game.
And suddenly you have a few hundred cards
which you and your team could study.
This is how they prepared by memorizing
literally thousands of moves,
tens of thousands, maybe
hundreds of thousands.
But where Fred comes in is in the 80s he
convinced the Russian Federation to put
this online
where anyone could study it and add
to it and suddenly this book explodes,
which is for some people,
distressing people tend to boom me
sometimes when I come into the trust
tournament today, they
will point to me and say,
that's him Frederick the man who ruined
chess because here's the modern game.
When two players sit down at one
of these tournaments to face off,
they've already consulted
Fredrick's database,
which he's named Fritz Trust plays old
call fritzy now and because of fritzy
they walk into these games with so
much of the book in their heads,
that whole portions of the game
are very checkers, like very rote.
You'll see this if you watch
grandmasters play speed chess,
that's Brian Christian again.
They'll just hammer out the first
dozen or so moves, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam,
Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam with
barely any thought memory. Yeah,
it used to be two, three, four,
five, six moves. No big deal.
Nowadays it is 16 moves, 20 moves.
There does seem to be a kind
of creep that's happening.
The book is getting bigger and bigger,
but inevitably in every chess game there
is a moment which puts the book in its
place and if you watch a game,
is there a chess tournament coming
up that like a big one? Yes.
Next Thursday I'm going to Romania where
some of the top players are playing.
If you watch a game as I was able to do,
because you can watch these
games online. Okay, yeah.
We're going to watch a chess tournament
online. You will see that moment. Yes.
That's, it's not like, you know,
Jordan's scoring 40 points while he
has a fever and it's not like that,
but if you know what to look
for, it's quite profound. Okay.
It's 8:30 AM I'm here with my little man.
They high and somewhere in Romania,
two grand masters are about to sit down
at a table to do battle and I will watch
it virtually the batch I
watched with Magnus Carlsen,
the world's top player versus
a Kuru Nakamura, the u s champ.
I call up Frederick.
Hello Frederick to give me the play by
play cause I actually don't know much
about chess.
Well his program Frisk can tell you how
many times each move has occurred in the
entire recorded history of chess.
What does that mean?
It's like his computer can look at the
board and say that that move you just
made.
That has happened before and I will tell
you exactly how many times before it
started. Here we go with one white moves,
it's d for to d
white phone, two squares forward.
My database tells me that there are
1,775,000 games in which this occurred.
Then we have two black counters with
it's pond going from c four to east six.
Now we've got two ponds facing
each other, middle of the board,
and according to Fred's database. This
exact configuration has occurred in
514,518 games.
A million and a half down to
half a million smaller. Yes.
Lose three white moves in other parts.
335,000 plants and another pond.
149,000 smaller moves. It's
nice. 114,000 black moves,
especially at 91,000 west. Again,
white pontics of black bond just
have our first casualty people.
2,428 games. What was that again?
2,400 Oh last time response.
2,613 games like the ship
flies across the board.
2001 and 25 games. [inaudible]
moves another pond up.
1,200 weight queen does a little thing
where you 181 games 381 get lower.
Yes. Black bishop retreats. 19 games,
thank t one nine white lose another
pond which has occurred in 11 games.
Gay Black Bishop Retreats, 11
games. White Bishop advances.
We've down to 10 game 10 woo black
fish and falls back even further.
And we have nine game. Black
bishop takes white fish pies,
game white pawn retaliates taking
black bishop oh five game and then
[inaudible]
white rook and white kings switch places.
No, there are no more games.
You have a position which has
never occurred before. Indian verse
ever.
No. In the universe.
Not In the history of this university
and this is what is known as the novelty,
the novelty, the novelty, you
and in chest notes. If
you read chess notes,
you will see the charts after this
move. The annotator writes out to,
yeah, out of book,
I buy a book which means no more book.
Both sides now are on their own
and everyone we talked to who plays
chess told us that when you get to that
moment and you feel you're alive
in a way that you're not normally.
That's Frank Brady,
he's an author and a professor at St
John's international harbor of the World
Chess Federation. You're totally in it.
Your mind is in some
ways not even operating.
It's like you're back to being
three again. What are you saying?
I'm saying this is one of the reasons
we watch sports for these kinds of like
zero moments position,
which was never occurred.
India the same time the zero is happening
inside all of these rules which are
like our lives. This is
what else was saying.
Games let us experience the world in
both those ways. At the same time.
The Pacers could fail. For example,
here's one 1999 Nix Pacers.
Larry Johnson has the ball, nicks
are down by three final seconds.
He has no shot best. You think he could
do his tie but he has no shot. Yeah,
and then somehow you twist the shimmies.
He moved to the left, throws it up.
It's fine.
[inaudible]
that was like, what? What?
I mean that's in the rules,
but nobody could have imagined that
position, which was never occurred. India,
I don't know about. Never went. No mind
you sure? Yeah. This is a hockey moment.
It's Wayne Gretzky,
early nineties he's playing
chutes for the goal of the plaque.
It's something somebody who starts flying
through the air, like a tennis ball.
When you get ski, turns around and
lacks the flying out of the air.
[inaudible]
to smacked it out of the air.
The universe would have to be extremely
old to have a previous version of that.
Frank, do you have a number one
favorite novelty in chess? Well,
my number one favorite would be Bobby
Fischer's game of the century and went and
when did that happen?
We're jumping to 1956 Bobby is 13 years
old and you see the Bobby Fischer of
legend at this point, or just
a 13 year old 13 year old kid.
He got invited to this tournament.
It was an all adult invitational
tournament and frank
says all the world's best
were there.
And this was kind of Bobby Fischer's
first official match in the big leagues,
so to speak. Exactly. And to set the
scene, it was October warm Indian summer.
We were at the Marshall
Chess Club in Manhattan,
which to speak Stodgy brownstone
with lots of Mahogany.
And Bobby Fischer in his t-shirt sits
down to play a fellow named Donald Bern,
a guy who looked apart a very urbane
sophisticated jacket, bow tie,
always had a cigarette
between two fingers.
Imagine who had been hard for him to
take this kid seriously and he was not
doing all that well. From the beginning.
Bobby Fisher was making what looked like
dumb errors he was losing. For example,
midway through the game,
Bobby made this move where he moved
as night to the rim of the board,
which is usually strategically speaking
is not the greatest place to move your
night cause you know if your
nights chuffed against the edge,
it's boxed in and the night could
be taken and people should watt.
What is it that he blunder? Come
on kid. Yeah, this is crazy.
But then Bobby Fisher does
something truly crazy.
What he leaps so far out of the book and
offense that people are still talking
about this move. 50 years
later on the 18th move,
he allowed Byrne to take his
queen. He just said, here,
take my queen now in chess.
That's like crazy. Yeah.
In chess it's almost impossible to
where the gay or if you lose your queen,
it's like what? That's got to be wrong.
That must be a stupid blunder that it
seemed like maybe he was throwing in the
towel.
So a crowd gathers grumb of people hanging
around to watch this kid get put in
this place and Bern did what
anyone would do in that situation.
He took the queen, but
maybe four moves later.
Just at the moment you would think
he would have Bobby Fischer in a
stranglehold. Bobby started checking
king, he was chasing
burn all over the board.
People began to see that
there was some combination,
but it was a long
combination and you know,
20 moves later burn was done. Both.
He was checked by [inaudible] and frank
says if you analyze the game you see
that it all began and in a way
ended when he sacrificed as queen.
What was the last game from that
moment? Burn didn't take the queen.
He was lost. This bird took
the queen. He was lost the way.
Are you saying he essentially
checkmated him 20 moves at a time? Yes.
It was unstoppable. It was forceful.
So it's like he wrote a new book,
he stuck the guy in his book. I love
that. So it's Kinda interesting.
You can start the game in book,
so to speak and you're kind of
locked into a set of moves. Yeah,
the game ends kind of
the same way. Same Way.
That's destiny [inaudible] but then
in the middle you just get a peak at
something infinite, infinite.
Although we were wondering like is that
middle space really infinite by applying
the rules?
I mean we asked Frederick if people
play chess for hundreds and hundreds of
years, venting new moves into that
empty space. Would they ever fill it up?
And he said no,
because the number of chess games that
are possible is vastly more than the
number of atoms in the universe is a
silly little number compared to the number
of testing the numbers.
How many alums either in the universe
or what 10 to the power of 82 the last
time I counted up, no, 78 82 zeros.
10 to the power of 78 I think
70 accurate and there are more.
There's abilities within
a 40 move chess game,
10 to the power of 120 approximately.
And he says if he were to try to get
all that information into fritzy his
database,
we would have to dismantle an entire solar
system just to store the information.
And he says you'd have to dismantle
another one. Just to plug it in.
[inaudible]
and what he says about chess, if
you could say that about hockey,
you could see that about baseball.
You could say that about curling,
but you can not say that about
checkers. Like clear. So check inside.
Every game has this kind of strange
thing. It has a field of play,
small little box. It'd be a board,
it could be a field, whatever.
And then you step into
it and there's like a
[inaudible]
I assume system
[inaudible].
Thanks to Alison Gopnik, she wrote the
wonderful book, the philosophical baby,
and Frank Brady, who is the author
of end game, Bobby Fischer's,
remarkable rise and fall. And also Brian
Christian who wrote the book the most.